what's up guys this is Rob and before we
start this video kevin conroy the voice
of Batman from Batman the Animated
Series has a message for you guys this
is Batman calling from Wayne Manor with
a shout out for the Rob core Robert
really appreciates you
he knows he's so fortunate to have you
in his life this is a shout out just for
you I am vengeance I am the knight I am
Batman and remember Rob Gore it's not
who you are underneath it's what you do
that defines you okay now this is Kevin
you know one of the things I've noticed
at Comic Cons it's the incredible sense
of community among the Batman fans and
it's a great sense of brotherhood and I
I get a feeling that you and the Rob
Corps are sharing that and I think
that's wonderful I think it's great so
keep it up and I really appreciate the
interest you show in my work so good
luck and remember Batman's got your back
okay so we are getting into or getting
back into the Avengers vs. x-men stories
we're really just the vs. series and in
this one we're covering the fight
between storm and black panther and this
is really one of the more interesting
fights but also because of the history
between the two right like there's a lot
of history when it comes to storm black
panther um and it's one of these funny
things right because when it when you
look at the history of it it gets kind
of murky right so for those of you guys
who are familiar with this bear with me
for the people who are not right I want
to kind of run over this and explain it
up until 2006 the the idea of storm and
black panther having a romantic
relationship and being together was
something that was never really explored
the only exception to that came in 1980
with Marvel team-up issue number 100
right and the idea was that storm
basically met Black Panther for the
first time because they both hail from
Africa it was a huge focal point of
their characters
and it was kind of like let's you know
kind of see how people react to this
right but there wasn't really anything
done with it besides that now they did
kind of meet you know occasionally
between now and then and there was this
idea of a romance between the two but
you know they never really explored it
why normal it really took the time to
explore that and see like let's see
where this goes this changed in 2006 in
a couple of different stories the first
one is the really storm vol 2 it's her
second miniseries was written by Eric
Jerome Dickey and that came out in 2006
the second part was Reginald Hudlin run
on black panther which came out at the
same time and the reason for that is
because Marvel was building up to a
marriage between storm and black panther
the idea was was really between this
miniseries by Erik Jerome and Reginald
Hudlin run that essentially you learned
that storm had actually met black
panther when they were little kids and
seemed to kind of fall in love but the
problem with this is that two challahs
duties as the heir to the black panther
line taking over for his father came
before anything else right he was going
to be king of a country and that was the
most important thing for him to focus on
so the result was that they never really
got a chance to explore the relationship
over time as white panther played his
part and really kind of opened up
Wakanda to the rest of the world and a
storm eventually went on to join the
x-men that he ultimately came back into
contact with each other and that's where
things kind of picked up with Black
Panther issues 15 through 18 right 15
was kind of like the exploring the past
between Black Panther and storm
alongside storms miniseries issue number
18 was the official marriage between
Black Panther and storm the results of
that is they ended up getting married in
Black Panther vol 4 issue number 18
during the Civil War event right and it
kind of created a truce right the idea
was that all the superheroes and the
x-men were invited but they couldn't
fight each other right so it was kind of
a chance to air grievances and nobody
really took advantage of it and so then
you had this this these line of comics
called world tour really kind of
continued on and the Black Panther story
but who is basically Black Panther world
tour or like they went to Latveria they
went to go see dr. doom and doctor dooms
like congratulations and all that comes
to a head in Avengers vs. x-men now the
biggest shame and this this is the
biggest the biggest problem with storm
and and Black Panthers marriage is model
never really explored it right they
never really had like the this great big
huge on running you know like maxi
series right like a 12 issue maxi series
where was like exploring the
relationship we're exploring their
marriage or even within the confines of
the comic writing or even you know with
Black Panther itself or even in the
x-men comics one of these things where
it was never really explored in the way
that it could have been and really made
it more interesting and solidified and
so when Avengers vs. x-men kicked off a
storm ended up siding with the x-men
black panther sided with the Avengers
and that began the rift by the time that
Namor the Submariner had become one of
the Phoenix five and destroyed what
Conda for the most part this basically
he had stormed align yourself with the
x-men themselves and ultimately black
panther labeling the x-men as enemies of
the state right they were enemies of
Wakanda and the result of this is that a
kind of solidified storm you're no
longer welcome here why not me she kind
of was because she was still the Queen
at the time at least when this story
kicks off but what this does is it
really kind of has the two of them
coming into contact with each other now
the crazy thing about this is that with
this this fight between the two store
like right off the bat channels
lightening right it immediately goes to
attack attack Black Panther and
initially she kind of gets the upper
hand but the funny thing about this is
that the Charla you know it's almost
kind of like you know Jason Aaron in
this bit of a story almost kind of
invokes this black pant I'm sorry this
this Batman thing where it's like a
black panther and I'm prepared for every
eventuality right you know and and
there's there's a reason for this and it
actually really kind of solidifies why
their marriage was an OLE in the first
place but the idea here is a black
panther basically absorbing the
lightning that that storm channels adam
and then fires it right back at it right
so it's almost kind of this bishop
effect but it's crazy because as this is
going on he really kind of you know
black panther kind of muses were kind of
talks to himself and says like you know
like the the pain of experiencing this
is unbearable but it's nothing compared
to the look on her face right because
one thing to understand what the two of
them fighting each other like this it's
a crushing experience right because
they're they were kind of forced to
choose sides now the reality is that
with storm having been married to black
panther
but also having led having having been a
part of the x-men what this did this is
one of those important things to
understand here with storm being the
queen of Wakanda but also being an x-man
probably made her the single most
important mutant in the world right
because she was the liaison between
Wakanda and the rest of the world right
you know and so because I was it was a
pretty significant thing that's why the
marriage a storm of like Panther is so
astronomically important because it
really kind of changed the dynamic you
know of storm as a character but it's
such the two of them have to fight each
other because they pick sides right
Black Panther kind of looked at that and
said like the x-men aren't really right
here right like you know the the idea of
the Phoenix returning is a credible
threat to earth and it's gonna manifest
in some form or fashion which it did
right the Phoenix was broken into five
pieces and then it bonded to five
different individuals so yes it was a
credible threat in yes the Phoenix you
know we really proved itself to
be a credible threat but only because
Tony Stark made it that way right so
it's like the one thing the Black
Panther doesn't really seem to be
acknowledging here and so the result is
that again these two people taking sides
they end up going to conflict with one
another the funny thing about this is
that Black Panther basically says like
you know I'm well aware of my wife's
powers where she controls the the
elements themselves right any world that
she's on she can control the elements
earth is no different than any other
planet and so what he basically says is
like as the black panther I've been
trained in essentially every single
martial art on the planet right black
panther basically says with all the
martial arts that I've been trained with
what I've learned is that every punch
can be countered there's a counter for
everything out there and what he had
been doing and this was really one of
the one of the most sinister things of
his character what he had been doing was
basically working on finding ways to
neutralize the powers of storm that in
the event that something like this went
down that like he'd have a way to
basically counter her now on one part it
makes sense if they weren't married
right like if they were not married and
yeah it would make sense to say okay
let's find a way like neutralize of
harsher body else like you don't plot
against your wife like that that's the
crappiest thing ever she's like the one
person in the world you can trust more
than anybody else right so like the
results of this is is is really like a
massive betrayal and mass house storm
sees it she's like what happened to my
power and he basically says like I just
neutralized what it wasn't you were
gonna do right like I neutralized you
know the winds and everything this storm
that you were bringing here done right
this this this huge snowstorm you're in
a cause done the winds neutralizing I
basically I didn't really shut down or
he didn't shut down her powers but he's
like I basically shut down what it was
that you were going to do basically
manipulated the weather to take away
what it was that she was going to do but
regardless essentially it's just kind of
like you've basically had a plan for how
to fight your wife and so the result
here is a black panther is no longer
fighting a wife who believes that she's
right now he's fighting an angry wife
and that's probably the worst
circumstance to be that's probably the
biggest problem so basically like you
know storm kind of starts to get the
upper hand on black panther now one
thing to also understand here this was
kind of a kind of an important thing to
bear in mind here while the fight does
appear pretty even it's important to
note the Black Panther is kind of
pulling his punches and the reason why a
storm is an exceedingly capable fighter
right it's not design yeah I'm not
saying that to kind of knock her from
from you know saying that she's not a
pretentious fighter she is she's been
trained by Black Panthers she's been
trained by Wolverine
you've been trained by some very capable
individuals out there but
pound-for-pound blow-for-blow when it
comes to techniques she's not on the
same level is to chala and so the fact
that he doesn't in this fight like that
really sort of indicated he's kind of
pulling his punches here it doesn't
really look like he's actually you know
looking to literally crush his wife
right it looks more just kind of like
disable her or to basically keep her
from attacking him but here's the other
funny thing that kind of goes on this is
one of the important things to
understand here one of the things that
we sort of learned you know from what we
did see with the mayors between Black
Panther and storm is there were a lot of
things that weren't talked about right
there were there are a lot of sessions
that weren't hot and that's one of the
important things you know to kind of
sidetrack from this for a second in any
relationship that's the most important
thing right like it's better to have a
conversation and four things should just
kind of go nuts and you guys just just
you know do to air all your laundry then
to never have those conversations right
to never never have those talks right
that's what relationships are hardest
because you're gonna bump heads and
you're gonna argue and you're you're
you're gonna get into into debates and
you're gonna get into situations where
you know you're kind of going back and
forth on stuff but that's the nature of
a relationship is to find some kind of
commonality and sometimes it gets to a
point where you can where you basically
find irreconcilable differences right
you want one thing she wants another and
it's impossible for you to compromise it
just cannot it cannot be done and the
results of the relationship cannot
continue but what storm and black
panther seemed to never do or have those
discussions right to air that dirty
laundry and it is kind of throw it out
there instead it seemed like they were
eternally in the honeymoon phase right
now a lot of that was because it seemed
like there was no time for that you know
storm was always on a mission with the
x-man and black panther was always doing
something in Wakanda and there was never
really any time for them to actually be
a married couple and that was really it
right to focus on their marriage outside
of their initial honeymoon and that's
why you see them having these opposing
views and it's almost like they never
really even know each other at all and I
mean you see like personality traits
being thrown out you know for example
she says the Black Panther was always
too cold which is true Black Panther in
a lot of ways is kind of detached from
the rest of the world and his response
was she was always to hot-blooded which
is also true right like storm is always
kind of you know she's one of these
characters in more recent years not
really in the old school days I should
have flare up and just you know just
just kind of start going off but it was
one of these one of these things where
he says Black Panther says she was never
going to be happy here storms thought I
could have been so happy here you know
like Black Panthers by Panthers thoughts
thank God we never had children
storms idea if we only ever had children
things may have been different
right so this seems like they don't
really know each other at all and that's
one of the crazy things writing sooner
they kind of jumped in there and never
really took the time to understand what
the other wanted in this this particular
circumstance never aired this dirty
laundry which is the necessity when it
comes to any kind of a relationship and
so ultimately you know the storm kind of
goes in and basically says like like
this this ants right this is all over if
this ends now and the result is that of
course she basically kisses white
panther and then punches them right and
when the rest of the wakandan
individuals show up and they say hey
like you know what's what's going on
like what one the one in the world is
taking place here storm takes her ring
off and throws it on the ground and
basically says we're finished right this
this wedding is done like we we our
business is it there's there's no more
we're not married anymore and that's
really kind of how their their marriage
came to an end now the funny thing about
this is Jason Aaron really kind of ends
this was like who's the winner there are
no winners here I want to know who you
think is the winner right but this is
how the marriage of storm and black
panther came to an end now for the
living guys who were reading tana ha
seacoast black panther run is basically
coming back right the idea of storm of
black panther kind of rekindling their
relationship is coming back
and with tanto ha see coach at the helm
because he's such an amazing writer on
black panther so long as it stays that
way he'll explore the heck out of it
right i'm i don't know if he's actually
done it yet i believe he has but it'll
certainly be explored it's a pretty
fantastic way so you know it's been
building up for a long time i believe
it's already started if they're not
already back together again
I'm not as current as I should be on
black panther shame on me but the fact
remains you know this this is really
kind of how this ends right it's it's
like the other ones that we've seen
we're just sort of ends and and
seemingly with a kind of non victor
right we don't really see anybody get
pummeled to the ground and absolutely
destroyed but yeah so we're gonna bring
this video to an end guys if you are new
here two comments exclaimed make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you